[Musique]
combien valait une peau de castor au
début du 20e siècle au début des années
1900 un trappeur pouvait obtenir une
quinzaine de dollars pour une peau de
castor ce qui correspond après de 400
dollars aujourd'hui une petite fortune
on se servait notamment de cette
fourrure pour fabriquer des chapeaux au
cours du siècle dernier les prix ont
beaucoup fluctué et aujourd'hui une
podcastor ne rapporte toujours qu'entre
15 et 25 dollars autant dire presque
rien comme la trappe est peu rentable la
population de castor à Bondy certains
estiment qu'elle serait dix fois plus
importante qu'à l'époque de la Nouvelle
France une augmentation stimulée par
l'activité humaine notamment la
surexploitation forestière qui a laissé
la place aux jeunes feuillus nourriture
idéale du castor le plus grand rongeur
au pays est d'ailleurs un travailleur
acharné qui peut abattre jusqu'à 200
arbres par année